-We love having you here,
so thanks so much
for coming back to
see us, buddy.
I have a lot of things to
talk to you about.
I don't even know
if I even thanked you
for what you did for
the frontline workers
and the nurses here in New York.
You performed in
a flatbed truck,
went all around New York City.
I thought it was so cool
that you did that.
Anyways, you've done that.
You performed
at the Super Bowl, okay?
You performed in the
NBA All-Star Game.
But now you had even
bigger dream come true.
This is something that
is insane,
and I got to say, I have friends
that are superfans of WWE.
They don't mess around.
They are superfans.
So when they see somebody do
something dumb, they go,
"No, no, no."
They loved --
You wrestled in the WWE,
and you were phenomenal.
You went to WrestleMania.
-Thank you.
-You jumped off the top rope!
-Yeah, I did it, I did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Was that just something you
always wanted to do
or do you like wrestling?
-Yeah, no, I've always been,
since I was a kid,
a wrestling fan.
And that was a dream come true.
I can't believe it yet,
you know?
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Did you train, like, for -
-A lot, a lot.
-You did. You had to.
You had to.
-Yeah.
-It looked so good.
-Yeah, I spent like
three months...
-Did you really?
-...training,
physically working hard,
you know, on my body and working
on the technique in the ring
with the pro, you know?
-I mean, it's real stuff.
I mean, if you ever go see
wrestling in real life
and being there,
I don't know how they do this.
-No, me neither. Me neither.
-You get kicked in the face
and thrown around.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
Like, it's not --
I mean, it's not an act.
It's like, dude,
it's really physical stuff.
-Yeah, I receive a kick
in my chest.
It still hurt, you know?
-You still have a bruise.
-Yeah.
-I want to show some highlights
just so we can see
how fun you are.
Here's Bad Bunny in WWE.
Watch this.
-From Vega Baja, Puerto Rico,
Bad Bunny!
-I am --
-Oh!
-Oh-ho-ho!
-Look who it is!
-No, wait, wait.
What the hell is he doing?
Whoa!
-Oh, my God!
Are you kidding me?!
-Whoa!
-I've heard of flying squirrels,
but flying bunnies?!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You had that flip move.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I deserve the main event
the next year.
-Yeah, you do deserve
the main event, yeah.
I know you don't usually look
back on your concerts,
you told me, but you've watched
that over and over again?
-After WrestleMania,
I watched like the whole month,
every night before I go to the
bed, it watched the fight.
And it was -- Sometimes cried.
-Before bed,
did you just watch your --
-Yeah, yeah,
every night, every night.
-Last year,
you released two albums.
The most-streamed album
on Spotify.
You won a Grammy Award,
by the way, for it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you.
-And then -- and then,
not too long after that,
you released
"El Ultimo Tour Del Mundo."
-[ Speaks Spanish ]
-Yeah, yeah.
You're going to go on
tour next year.
I know you go all out,
but what can people expect
from Bad Bunny?
-Whew! Yeah, I'm crazy for
the start of that tour.
Will be epic.
You know, I always put --
try to do something
different for the people.
-The Puerto Rico show
is December 10th?
-That's my first concert since
two years ago, you know?
-Really?
-So it's going to be so special.
It's going to be --
I would put --
My shows always
are so hype, so fun,
but Puerto Rico shows
are different, you know?
That's my home, so I put
everything on that stage.
So I'm ready.
-December 10th that is.
-Yeah, December 10th.
-Alright, buddy, we'll be
sending you vibes from here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you've hinted, because
I follow you on the socials --
You're fun to follow.
But you've hinted at
maybe having another album
coming out maybe next year,
but nobody knows
the title or when.
You can't tell me anything.
But it -- Have you been --
have you been dropping clues?
Is there something --
-No say, no say.
I'm working on it, you know?
I don't have...
[ Speaks Spanish ]
But maybe, maybe
I left some clues.
I don't know. I don't know.
I'm not sure.
-You're not sure.
But maybe a couple Easter eggs?
-Eh...
-Ehh...
Ehhhhh....
Okay, yeah.
I mean. wait. 1966.
Does that number --
do they mean something, maybe?
-I don't know.
-No.
No.
-That's my stylist.
-Okay. So, everyone,
look at different socials
and things that Bad Bunny's
been doing,
because maybe, eh...
Eh....
-I'm not saying anything.
-We're not saying anything.
I want to talk to you about
your acting debut,
in "Narcos: Mexico,"
when we come back.
More with Bad Bunny
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.